[Music]
foreign
Edwards and I'm gagandeep Singh we are
solutions engineers at budget we work
with customers every day helping them
turn their data science work into apis
applications and reports that can be
used throughout their company we are
going to conduct a workshop at the Cs
project conference focusing on building
data science workflows in Python and we
would like to share top three reasons
you should consider attending
reason number one pipe bi has over 438
000 packages choosing the right tool for
the right job can be challenging do
people still use pandas as my API needs
to be async now we will discuss our
favorite open source python tools and
packages for developing end-to-end data
science applications number two
developing and deploying these python
applications is hard
how do I get my local web app to run in
a production environment how do I share
my dash application with others in this
Workshop we will introduce you to posits
professional products so that you can
get hands-on experience with solving
these problems lastly this Workshop will
be fun it will be a great place to meet
with your fellow pythonistas whether
you're a new python user or a seasoned
python veteran there'll be something at
this workshop for everyone we hope to
see you in Chicago for the first ever
posit conference
foreign